hello and welcome to this video playing
Yardbird let's try something else try
the trompe ok so my words my school
minus 5 that was bad at some point let's
see if we can Transposer yeah yeah it
said certainly true him he has well I
thought 94 actually oh gee 594 doesn't
work probably will get it some Queens
gambit after all it's a bit of an
uncommon Queens gambit position so let's
just develop him yet that looks like a
new zone now some limbs all with age 6
night 1d seven is a d5 good now ok let's
do it Bishop see 3d is 6 I thought
usually this kind of thing doesn't work
yet without Bishop one b7
well I simply forgot that this is a move
okay and I take these seven and the
touch gives away stuff
and what about what about Queenie to
Bishop takes a 17 hmm that doesn't
doesn't do all that much ok so let's
play the simple move then and yeah I'm a
pawn down somehow I could have taken f6
he has to take with the g pawn and queen
d 3 and then Queen g6 ah mmm very very
stupid stuff and very simple stuff ok
yeah it's so interesting at least
check
okay and I can take with an idea also a
taking of a queen cream cakes and then
take on v1 also isn't bad certainly not
um still night cheeks I don't have a
great discovery with that night is the
problem can also just take V 1 this is
also attacked hey I'm playing to slow
him
our kids a good move a good defense I
don't like to trade but I probably have
to Queen B seven would be a move to
avoid the trade route b8 Brooke check
twin takes a sound very computer ish
clean you five create queen if for stuff
like that and then just know why they
cannot go Queenie phone so maybe I can
play that and maybe he can go b8 Queen a
725 I can play Bishop of six first ok
this one okay which me I can keep queens
on and attack the bishop maybe Quincy to
yeah I have to put it somewhere where
it's not attacked now as bishop is
hanging and his rookie saying aunt a bit
in the night when you for probably save
some it's a funny yeah it's so funny
time Jay
it's nachi for working edit that would
be absolutely crazy ok at least I have
it long after that if if it plays it
Queen f7 em I can now ki can actually
win even shoot I want to our player
don't tell me I don't have a move yet
that would be awful and I don't have a
move him Oh white resigns yeah this is
this is terrible to lose this game
because it was just so completely
winning at least I think that that was a
win at this when this was flight here
yeah this is winning takes takes takes
Queen d3 isn't that winning I bishop e6
ok this is this is working um ok but
rupee three wins I mean it's impossible
that this shouldn't shouldn't be good I
just this is a totally brain-dead move
95 completely idiotic I mean if he if I
can't force him to take with the paw and
I have to do it and this is not exactly
difficult it's just a very simple win
but even afterwards i don't i don't
believe justice for black arrow or shine
so let's let's have a look that was
extremely complicated of course and the
string of only moves I think for maybe
for both sides and this is this is
amazing I mean this is a terrible move
right here in TX h 4 i'm sorry you
cannot let this night exist in this too
and the only problem was that i played
this move which going back into the game
after f4 Queen d3 it's basically over
again the queen is offside and how can
you let this night live with all those
weaknesses so it was just playing for
wind or whatever I don't know it just
has to take here and and it's okay for
him yeah but okay look you want 3d fours
again this is strong and now it works
out shine yeah I wanted to play a four
and still I wanted to get this situation
in that I could have had before and um
yeah and this this losses due to queens
III wow what a terrible loss those are
those are the worst one say you get get
wins like you on a silver plate don't
don't take them and then and you lose to
something like this anyway thanks for
watching